[Música]
[Aplausos]
estoy en el metro
salí de clases está estudiando la
maestría en fotografía en madrid y estoy
sentada en el metro y no puedo dejar de
ver a de un chico que iba en el vagón
era un nigeriano
que no cruzaba su mirada con nadie
estaba como desconectada solamente
viendo hacia el piso viendo hacia afuera
del vagón
y nadie lo veía él tampoco como si no
existiera y esto me impresionó muchísimo
baje del tren me fui caminando a mi casa
pero no podía dejar de pensar en él
estaba pensando en este chico en su
historia
realmente podía haber sido cualquier
historia pero lo que sí era real es que
este chico no existía
a lo que él se enfrentaba todos los días
era una civilización
que lo tenía anulado
tantas historias de migrantes
que empecé a ver en madrid al crecer yo
en ciudad juárez
conozco estas historias y es parte de mi
realidad pero ahora me encontraba en la
otra parte del mundo
y yo también viviendo una especie de
choque cultural donde no podía encontrar
la relación hacia esta nueva ciudad en
donde vivía
empiezo a buscar por medio de mi
historia cómo relacionarme y no puedo
evitar voltear a ver a los migrantes
esta ciudad madrid está lleno de
migrantes de todas partes del mundo y
empiezo a observar y no pude evitar
dirigir mi mirada hacia el migrante
porque porque al crecer yo en la
frontera de ciudad juárez el paso texas
es lo que soy en la frontera y es algo
muy común para mi entonces como encontré
yo esa conexión específicamente en la
mirada de la gente
todos conocemos esa mirada de los
migrantes
esa mirada
con un abismo
esa mirada desconectada desterrada
así que
empecé mi búsqueda fotográfica y un buen
día mi hermosa madre que me conoce muy
bien que sabe exactamente lo que está
pasando conmigo me manda un anuncio de
periódico de un hombre que introduce en
su cuerpo adentro
de un coche para tratar de cruzar la
frontera de juárez el paso y me
impresionó me impactó tanto me quedé sin
palabras la verdad
más allá de pensar yo le pobre hombre
que tuvo que hacer esto pensé que
pantalones de hombre que se metió
adentro de un carro para cruzar la
frontera qué valentía que como cómo
haces eso y la valentía que te produce
llegar a ese límite es la desesperación
y la crisis
empiezo a investigar otras historias en
madrid' en otras partes del mundo y
empiezo a descubrir todas estas
historias de fronteras de personas que
cruzan de formas increíbles son los que
están desesperadas y que necesitan una
salida una nueva vida y son capaces de
arriesgar hasta su propia vida
entonces
empiezo a volcarme en esta serie que se
llama borders
y empiezo a encontrar historias de
personas que cruzan
formas impensables solamente una mente
desesperada puede llegar a pensar voy a
meter adentro de un colchón no voy a
meter adentro de una silla para cruzar
y la intención de estas fotografías es
abordar el tema de migración que en
muchas partes del mundo ya se ha
convertido en una especie de cliché el
migrante la lucha todo esto pero como
puedo hablar de este tema y volver a
sensibilizar y volver a llamar la
atención
el espectador así que en ese momento
pensé en crear un espacio blanco y
colocar solamente el objeto y la persona
así que dedicarnos nada más a ese
momento en donde el migrante ya dejo
su camino su vida pasada todavía no
llega al futuro está en medio de la nada
flotando sin saber qué va a pasar
esta es la recreación de la foto
que del periódico que les platico que me
mandó mi mamá
y me volqué me vacié en esta serie como
nunca
de hecho el día de la sesión llegue con
fiebre llegue enferma llegué sin dormir
llegué sin energía ya porque tenía tres
meses consiguiendo las cosas con mis
amigos estudiantes y estuvimos la verdad
metiendo entregándonos por completo y el
día de la serie que llegó así empiezo a
sentir la historia la fuerza de las
historias y esto es lo que me me levanta
y empiezo a sentir las energía y nunca
en mi vida me había pasado esto nunca
había conectado de esta forma y nunca
había sentido la seguridad de que estaba
haciendo exactamente lo que quería hacer
y diciendo lo que quería decir era una
fuerza una exactitud que no
no recuerdo haber sentido antes
después de eso tengo la fortuna de que
gracias a esta serie
me dejaron en la ciudad de nueva york y
me voy para allá y llego
y me encuentro con un bloqueo bloqueo
donde no puedo fotografiar no me
interesa lo que estoy viendo a pesar de
que estaba en la capital del mundo
me sentía abrumada asfixiada con
muchísima información y porque porque
era el 2010 y ciudad juárez se estaba
haciendo catalogada la ciudad más
violenta del mundo y yo no podía
conectarme
toda esta superficie que estaba frente a
mí yo solo quería regresar a juárez y
venir
y ver lo que estaba sucediendo mi mamá
estaba aquí mis hermanos toda mi familia
mis amigos mi casa era mi casa y este
título de la ciudad más violenta del
mundo no personaje tan desconectado
a lo que yo conocía de mi casa
qué podía hacer yo en ese momento
regreso
y encuentra un grupo increíble de
fotógrafos que se unen a un proyecto
llamado inside out este proyecto
fue el ganador del premio ted en el 2011
y es un proyecto que trabaja
en ciudades en conflicto volteando las
de adentro hacia afuera para mostrar
otro rostro que no es ese conflicto
entonces entre todos es un grupo no nada
más de 16 fotógrafos sino de muchísimos
voluntarios que se unieron a tomar mil
rostros de gente de juárez y del paso y
tratar de mostrar esta otra cara que
también era real
estos mil rostros los pegamos en las
paredes del río bravo
y la verdad es que ahorita veo esta foto
y tengo como borrado ahorrado todo lo
que estábamos haciendo yo creo que en
ese momento ni siquiera me digamos en la
dimensión de lo que estábamos haciendo
estábamos haciendo un acto de
resistencia
estábamos movilizar no estábamos
moviendo a la comunidad a la ciudad para
despertar de este esta especie de
adormecimiento y para el parálisis de
tanto dolor
de la violencia de todo lo que estaba
sucediendo entonces este proyecto estoy
firmemente segura que fue uno de los
primeros que ayudó a sacudir en esta
etapa tan dura que vivimos
fue tan importante que empezamos nos
contactaron otros colaboradores de
inside out y quisieron hacer una
colaboración en donde intercambiamos
retratos entre 21 países estos retratos
se pegaron al mismo tiempo el día
internacional de la paz el 2012
fue algo importantísimo para nuestro
equipo para todos los colaboradores se
publicó un libro en francia donde
platica todos los detalles de lo que
sucedió
cuando termina este proyecto regresó a
la ciudad nueva york y estoy en
crecimiento y más crecimiento y qué pasa
que recibe una llamada que cambia mi
vida
y que tengo que regresar a la frontera y
esta vez definitivamente porque mi padre
enferma y me da la noticia de que queda
muy poco tiempo
así que regresó a juárez regresó al paso
esta vez me enfrento a otro tipo de
frontera una frontera que yo no conocía
a pesar de estar aquí en mi casa en la
frontera me estaba enfrentando a la
frontera entre la vida y la muerte
constantemente porque por medio de la
enfermedad de mi papá estaba en
constante contacto con la muerte al
mismo tiempo tuve la fortuna de ser
madre de dos hijos y estaba viviendo la
vida entonces era era una intensidad
entre la despedida y la bienvenida y qué
hago y entonces la vida me sube el
volumen a todo lo que da y se
intensifica todo y no puedo
no ver lo que está pasando aquí con esta
crisis humanitaria con migración
me invitan a un evento que se llama
hacks networks
y este evento es un maravilloso evento
que sucede en el río
otra vez después de inside out me
encontraba en el río en este símbolo que
nos define como frontera y que nos
separa pero que también nos une es
también la unión de estos dos países y
estaba aquí otra vez trabajando y me
sentía tan
tan fuerte de volver a estar aquí sentía
de alguna manera como si estuviera
quirúrgicamente trabajando en esta
cicatriz
y este este evento
en este caso fue a través del muro
muchas veces es en medio del río en este
caso fue a través del muro porque el río
estaba lleno de agua
les permiten a las familias reunificarse
y abrazarse por tres minutos
estas familias que han sido separadas
por años por toda la política migratoria
que existe
[Música]
pues ahí me plantee un día en este
evento increíble donde
no podía retratar me tenía que limpiar
las lágrimas no podía retratar
y fui testigo de encuentros de familias
de
hijos conociendo a sus padres
a vuelos conociendo a nietos hermanos
que no se veían en 30 años ellos aquí se
están casando aquí podemos ver el anillo
se acaban de casar por medio del muro
tantas historias y solamente tienen tres
minutos para abrazarse
para mí este acto de unión
simboliza algo importantísimo y una
esperanza que al menos yo necesito para
poder seguir
cuando imaginamos que ya todo está
acabado que el mundo se está derrumbando
luego existen estos eventos
y es muy fuerte
obviamente este evento me marca
me meto muchísimo en estas historias en
pensar en esos tres minutos le pregunté
una señora usted qué piensa de que son
tres minutos nada más me dice yo
solamente de volver a tocar a mi hijo es
una eternidad no me importa nada más
quiero volver a tocarlo
estando aquí en la frontera otra vez de
nuevo en medio de esta crisis
humanitaria que puedo hacer no vuelvo a
preguntar así como cuando estaba en
nueva york cuando estaba en madrid y
ahora estoy aquí y qué puedo hacer aquí
un buen día junto con samuel mi esposo y
mabel una amiga nos vamos a los centros
de migración y empezamos a hablar con la
gente con la situación
para conocer las historias que es lo que
está pasando es un oleaje de personas
que se han venido hacia la frontera
que empiezo a observar
como puedo hablar de estas historias sin
arriesgar los
y que nosotros podamos conectarnos a
a estas historias
pensé en los objetos en los que cargan
esta maleta que ellos hacen ahorita
están en el límite de su viaje ya
llegaron aquí a la frontera ya fueron
despojados de todo
se encuentran aquí muchas veces ya con
solamente una bolsa de basura
con sus pertenencias más importantes y
lo último que les queda
si ustedes se preguntan que meterían en
esa maleta si tuvieran que irse mañana
estas personas viven en el límite y
necesitan y son forzados a irse y
arriesgar a sus familias hay un poema de
una somalí inglesa que me llega
muchísimo que dice nadie pone a sus
hijos nadie los arriesga y los pone en
el mar al menos que el agua sea más
segura que la tierra
a eso eso es verdad me llegó muy
profundo porque ahora que soy madre por
supuesto por supuesto que no pones a tus
hijos y no los arriesgas al menos que no
haya otra manera otra salida
y estos son más objetos de personas que
están ahorita aquí
y estos objetos se vuelven kit en un kit
de sobrevivencia es ya dos son objetos
que cobran un valor
de vida o muerte de conexión al origen
son sus propias cosas y esto de nuevo
les digo es lo último que queda esta
serie se llama guard remains lo que
queda
nosotros como ciudadanos
en la frontera de méxico y eeuu
somos testigos constantemente
de estas historias cruzan constantemente
frente a nosotros estas historias de
despojo de violencia de desesperación de
angustia pero por favor no olvidemos que
también son historias de heroísmo de
valor de fuerza de voluntad de unos
pantalones para poder agarrar a tus
hijos y decir nos vamos
es importante desactivar las narrativas
de odio de discriminación
creo que
debemos hacerlo por medio de espacios de
reflexión
y creo firmemente que el arte es ese
espacio de reflexión gracias
[Aplausos]